a team of designers pour over 3d models
and intricate plans they're working on
the next generation of airline seating
and top-secret I can't show you that I'm
afraid I'm sorry I can't be more
specific James Park setup JPA design 20
years ago when we were all flying in the
equivalent of dentist's chairs his firm
helps change that these designing seats
that fully reclined with luxurious
materials that made us feel at home and
our challenge is to make make something
that is aesthetically pleasing that is
functional and it satisfies all these
requirements it's um it is quite a
demanding brief 40,000 feet above sea
level in below freezing temperatures
this is a hostile environment for luxury
seats can't just feel nice they have to
be safe safety is king of safety is
paramount in any ovation there
rigorously tested made to endure a
process rather ominous Lee called D
lethal ization if you were to experience
the extremes of the path of testing
limits of these seats are tested too
then I think that it would be quite
unpleasant the finished product is
unbelievably expensive a single
economy-class seat cost the airline as
much as a small car a first-class seat
try your house we have in fact worked on
a number of products which have been
award-winning and which have gone on to
sell great numbers and therefore the
unit cost comes down but they are
nonetheless expensive it's unavoidable
something worth thinking about next time
you spill a drink
Angus Bennett Bloomberg